et autres entretiens autour de l'ukraine
aujourd'hui celui entre les chefs de la
diplomatie américains et russes un
échange par téléphone entre sakai lavrov
et anthony blinken qui n'a pas permis de
désamorcer cette crise on en parle avec
un autre correspondant à washington
thomas bonnet bonsoir phoma que retenir
de ce coup de téléphone aujourd'hui
et bien c'est un entretien à
téléphonique entre sergueï lavrov et
anthony blinken qui a duré une trentaine
de minutes et ce qui est intéressant
dans ce genre d'exercice assez de
comparer la version des deux parties
prenantes à ces échanges on commence
avec le côté américain où il ya eu un
communiqué du département d'état qui est
finalement assez similaires à ceux ayant
suivi les précédents entretiens entre
les deux chefs des deux diplomaties
alors tout en appelant à maintenir le
dialogue avec moscou et washington il
réitère son attachement à la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et demande des
actes concrets à la russie écouter
le secrétaire d'état a exhorté à une
désescalade russe immédiate et au
retrait des troupes et des équipements
de la frontière ukrainienne il a
souligné qu'une invasion de l'ukraine
aurait des conséquences rapides et
sévère et a exhorté la russie à choisir
la voie diplomatique
et puis du côté russe on comprend que le
sujet est important c'est la demande de
moscou d'avoir des garanties sur une
expansion de l'otan vers les pays de
l'est et plus particulièrement en
ukraine sujet sur lequel est revenu le
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov avec une pointe d'optimisme
écoutez le
aujourd'hui j'ai confirmé à anthony
blinken que c'est un sujet que dont je
ne passeront pas sous silence nous
allons insister sur une conversation
franche sur une explication franche nous
voulons comprendre pourquoi les
occidentaux ne veulent pas remplir ses
obligations ou bien pourquoi ils le
veulent uniquement quand cela sert leurs
intérêts anthony blinken est d'accord
sur le fait qu'il ya un sujet à
éclaircir nous verrons où cela va mener
on comprend donc qu'il ya une forme de
statu quo dans les discussions
actuellement entre moscou et washington
à l'instant le porte-parole de la
diplomatie américaine a démarré une
conférence de presse il a dit que les
états unis attendaient toujours la
réponse de moscou aux demandes
américaines formulées à la semaine
dernière il explique qu'une voie
diplomatique est toujours possible mais
à condition d'une désescalade militaire
dans la région merci thomas bonnet en
direct de washington